[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing some of the more
confusing elements of the harry potter
story that's right
we're going to be talking about plot
holes before we get things started
let me just say this the established
magical world of harry potter
is fantastic and it was fantastically
written over the decades it has given
countless people an escape
a portal into a world much more magical
than our own
jk rowling before writing the books
spent years
planning out what she was going to write
and when pen finally went to paper
she did an excellent job but piecing
together the story and its characters
however with that said the story is not
perfect
and there are certainly some glaring
issues that have always stuck out to me
plot holes that weren't ever addressed
or any sort of addressed
in a tweet after the fact in this video
i'm going to be ranking
10 plot holes that stuck out to me
ranging from
more reasonable to questionable this
list
definitely won't include every plot hole
in the story
so don't attack me in the comments if
i've missed one instead
just comment a plot hole that stuck out
to you without further ado
let's get started 1. the financial
system
visiting money does it make any sense i
don't really think so
now let me start off by saying that just
because wizardkind is far more
independent than muggles
able to achieve all sorts of things
through magic it doesn't mean that their
society can operate
without a financial system currency
certainly exists in the wizarding world
existing in the form of galleons sickles
and cannots
there's even an established wizarding
economy allowing for
a medium exchange with goods services
so what's the problem here the problem
is that there is seemingly
no consistency with regards to what
things cost
or where this money actually comes from
in harry potter there are various
established bodies
including the ministry of magic hogwarts
and even a hospital
in a traditional economy these things
are paid for through taxes
etc what i wonder is aside from fines
how do these bodies obtain the necessary
income to support their basic
infrastructure
the next big issue stems from
inconsistencies i.e the cost of goods
drinks and sweets cost sickles and
canuts which makes sense
i guess but then a hogwarts textbook can
be as much as nine galleons
to a family like the weasleys one
galleon is a lot
so while they do obviously struggle it
just doesn't really make a lot of sense
to me
2. harry and thestrals our next plot
hole surrounds harry and
thestrals a breed of winged horse with
skeletal and reptilian features
that can only be seen by those who have
seen death
now before the events of the order of
the phoenix when harry can finally see
thestrals for the first time
we know that harry witnesses death on
numerous occasions
first when his parents died next when
quirrell died
and lastly and most recently in this
case when cedric
diggory died all of these deaths
actually occurred before the end of the
gobter fire
which is why it's interesting that harry
still couldn't see thestrals
at an earlier stage at the end of the
gobb to fire
the carriages still appeared horseless
to harry this is reinforced by page 629
so what gives why did it take so long
for harry to see them
as it turns out jk rowling has actually
addressed this plot hole herself
i've been asked this a lot harry didn't
see his parents die
he was in his cot at the time he was
just over a year old
and as i say in philosopher's stone all
he saw was a flash of green light
he didn't see quirrell's death either
harry had passed out before cruel died
and was only told about it by dumbledore
in the last chapter
he did however witness the murder of
cedric and it is this that makes him
able to see the thestrals at last
why couldn't he see the thestrals on his
trip back to the train station
well i didn't want to start a new
mystery which would not be resolved for
a long time
at the very end of the fourth book three
multiple ones
no which or wizard is complete without
their wand and more often than not
the wand is the instrument through which
they are able to channel most of their
power
they're made by wonder makers like
olivander not composed with a unique one
wood and one core additionally varying
in length and flexibility
in the series we see all sorts of
witches and wizards channeling magic
through their wands
but one part of the story stuck out to
me the time when harry
used multiple ones at once harry notably
ends up
leveraging multiple ones at once in
order to produce more power
casting an extra powerful spell against
fenrir greyback
my issue with this why does no one else
do it
if more ones equals more power then why
isn't everyone using
a couple of ones it doesn't really make
sense
4. veritas serum what's a verita serum
why a very powerful potion of course it
is verita's serum
a truth potion so powerful the three
drops would have you spilling your
innermost secrets
for this entire class to hear my
question here is
if truth serum exists in the magical
world why is it not used more often
couldn't truth serum dispel any doubts
about alliances
couldn't it eliminate the entire wizard
trial process
couldn't it have proven that sirius
black was in fact innocent
as it turns out rowling addressed this
later and confirmed that it is used
but that it can be beaten it is used but
skilled wizards can avoid its effects by
using antidotes and charms
a gifted oklahomans could also resist
verita's serum
5. secret keepers one of the reasons
that the potters died was because of
their chosen
secret keeper their good friend peter
pettigrew
a secret keeper is a witch or wizard
designated to hide a secret
secured by the fidelius charm which
conceals the secret
inside of the secret keeper's soul
initially
sirius black was chosen by james and
lilly but feeling that he would be an
obvious target for voldemort
sirius instead recommended peter who we
know doesn't do a particularly good job
the secret in question was the location
of the potter cottage
a secret that was tied to pettigrew's
soul unable to be forcibly removed
a dwelling protected by the fidelius
charm in conjunction with a secret
keeper
essentially becomes absolutely hidden
keeping the occupants safe
so the glaringly obvious issue here is
that james and lilly could have just
been their own
secret keeper they could have hidden
themselves away secure with their own
secret
and they would have never been found but
instead they chose one of their friends
which is nice but also doesn't make any
sense
6. the marauders map ah the marauders
map
an artifact capable of great mischief
the marauders map
as we know it was passed on to harry by
fred and george weasley
earlier on in the story however before
harry had it
fred and george had it for many years
stealing it from filtra's office
in just their first year at hogwarts
this plot hall surrounds both fred and
george's possession of the map
as well as who shows up on it you see
their dear brother ron had a pet rat by
the name of scabbers
ron had scabbers for many years before
his beloved rat is revealed to be death
eater
and ex-marauder peter pettigrew ron
slept with his rat
carried him around everywhere brought
him home brought him to hogwarts
and even brought him on the train so my
question is if fred and george could see
the name
peter pettigrew in constant proximity
with their brother
why didn't they say something they don't
even seem to notice
the other issue with this is that the
weasleys seem to be reasonably aware of
the intimate details
surrounding the death of the potter
family so you'd think
they'd recognize peter's name 7.
unbreakable vows
the unbreakable vow is a binding magical
contract that connects two parties
the purpose is simple it is to bind a
fellow witcher wizard to a promise
the participants stand opposite each
other and clasp each other's right hands
while a third party acts like a sort of
mediator or witness
and places the tip of their wand onto
the hands of the two participants
the mediator acts almost like a minister
and will begin to state conditions or
responsibilities related to the vow
after stating each condition of the vow
the participant who is told to uphold
said responsibilities
must agree to them one by one if you
fail to uphold your side of the bargain
after this type of vow you suffer the
ultimate consequence
death this seems like a pretty good way
of ensuring that people are on your side
yet in the story we really don't see
much of this happening
snape enters into one with narcissa
vowing to protect draco
but neither voldemort nor dumbledore
seem to be using this type of vow
to ensure that their followers allies
are indeed on their side
you'd think that an unbreakable vow
would be part of the death eater
initiation process
but it isn't there's a lot of deception
in the harry potter story
that could have been cleared up with a
simple vow
eight portraits early on in the story
we're introduced to the hogwarts magical
portraits
depicting witches and wizards from all
time periods
it is reinforced that the living
portraits in the wizarding world
are merely imprints of the dead person
capable only of imitating their basic
personality traits they don't have
feelings memories or any special
capabilities
like we may see with the ghost this is
all fine
however this explanation of portraits is
broken
when dumbledore's portrait is able to
communicate wisdom to snape
posthumously the sentient portraits are
certainly an area of the story
where some clarification is needed 9.
the elder wand
ah the elder wand one of the primary
drivers behind the story
and the most powerful wand in all of
existence the elder ones is responsible
for an incredible amount of death in the
story
an enigmatic artifact that is only made
even more enigmatic
to its unusual passing of ownership in
order to truly master the wand you must
become its true master
but this is where things get tricky the
one who purportedly only changes
ownership when its master
has truly been bested by another and
this is generally implied to be achieved
through murder however there are various
exceptions to this rule
like with grindelwald stunning
grigorovich malfoy disarming dumbledore
and harry finally disarming malfoy the
issue with this whole disarming thing
is that the wand is reinforced as this
unforgiving power-hungry object
wants to be matched with the most
powerful wizard around if that's the
case
then how can a much weaker wizard like
malfoy become its owner by simply
disarming
the extremely powerful dumbledore the
whole one to loyalty thing is a bit of a
mess
10. international wizarding community
perhaps the biggest pothole of all
to me is that in a wizarding world
emphasis on the world
that means the uk and all of the other
places on the planet
voldemort only seems to be a threat to
britain voldemort was an incredibly
powerful dark wizard
and if he truly came to power then he
would have been a threat to
everyone not just britain so my question
is
why didn't other wizarding communities
help why didn't other european countries
help
it just doesn't make sense and that
concludes my list of
my top 10 harry potter plot holes
comment your own
down below if you enjoy the content
please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
remember time will not slow down when
something unpleasant
lies ahead
you